dude yeah maybe if you got into that
[ __ ] cole chandra i think that that
could be interesting have you seen that
the travelers that fight over across the
pike he's over in like uh i don't know
what's that like snatch yeah the snatch
yeah you'd have travelers fighting when
you look up real quick and then like
like a gypsy like have you heard of
gypsy yeah like ramadi people like is
that what you're talking about
yeah the romney's romney shells or
whatever i don't even know like
[ __ ] travelers if you look at travelers
fighting on youtube
they just travel around just to fight
fools they're families of ancient
fighters
like they like their their great great
grandpas were fighters yeah
joyce do they just fight on the street
or they find people
on the street just like set up fight no
for money and like
traveler
this would be what you want to do so
what is this this is pike you can meet
up and fight over in ireland scotland
all the time just get out of the car and
start swinging they're families though
no
it's controlled this is gold already
look at that guy yeah they're all out of
shape
this is amazing if you're fighting in a
polo i respect you so much
that's what they do do they speak
english uh it's
dude it's a tough language it's a
version of english and that's the legend
of all of them big joe joyce right there
really in the white house yeah he's like
the mike tyson of gypsies oh this is
[ __ ] amazing
yeah dude well i gotta pull up to this
wherever this
place is i'm going yep and they
occasionally release videos on youtube
it's very rare but they and you
you start to get the whole like chain of
it all and how it's all built and
they're frowned upon over in europe like
gypsies because they don't
like they don't pay any taxes and
they're like steal [ __ ] and travel steal
travel and interesting culture though
yeah not
one girl there so that's the hell no
so it's our demos fellas so guys
it's also the united kingdom dog you've
been uh some places
in the uk
have you ever been swung on doing
anything yeah
is it documented nah i mean people
really don't swing often it's more like
actually swung on no
pushed mic grabbed people just like
[ __ ] with me i don't think people
swing on me that's good content though
oh yeah definitely you've been swung on
no no i was wondering if you put a mic
on somebody's face
i typically like use the mic as like a
magnet so people who want to be on
camera kind of find it
i don't really have to do anything you
just hold the microphone and people like
yeah i just kind of
i have a good sense of like seeing who
wants to be on camera i don't think i
ever like put a mic on someone who's
obviously not down because they could
easily just
smoke you but people don't want to punch
the random dude in a suit on the street
unless they're super crazy
what are you doing someone's just like a
boring ass interview you're just like in
your head you're like i'm not going to
use this
i just think of a way to cut it off
short you know all right well thanks for
talking to us man i appreciate you we're
going to keep moving bye
cool flat earth and then leave yeah yeah
shout out to beau baez
[Music]
is